the GPU market right now is starting to
remind me of a good old western duel it
seems that whoever reaches for their gun
first just ready to strike inand their
opponent ends up actually losing we saw
this happen with Nvidia's r-tx 2060 and
2070 super which at least on overall
value and price lose out to the RX 50
750 700 XT and today we could possibly
be seeing the same thing
aim DS new rx 5600 XT price matches the
gtx 660ti and claims to have better
performance and overall value today
we're going to see how much truth there
is to that statement and ultimately find
the best gaming GPU under 300 US dollars
so at two hundred and seventy nine US
dollars the rx 5600 XT is in a pretty
popular price bracket most gamers are
still using just 1080p resolution
monitors and high refresh rate panels
are becoming a lot more popular too and
so just like the 16 60 TI this card is
aimed at those wanting a high refresh
rate 1080p gaming experience and
potentially those wanting something for
entry-level 1440p gaming - now although
the new 5600 xt price matches the 1660
TR at 279 US dollars i don't actually
even recommend the 1660 TI in the first
place it's actually the cheaper gtx 1660
supe which makes a lot more sense based
on value it's only about 5% slower but
can be had for about $50 less and that
does make it the more sensible choice so
definitely keep an eye out for the gtx
1660 supe in the upcoming benchmarks
also I will note that in anticipation of
AMD's rx 5600 xt launch and video claims
to have dropped prices on some RT x 2016
models but at least on Amazon and Newegg
the RT X 2060 prices are still well into
the mid 300s if you can even find one in
stock actually you've got a much better
chance of finding an rx 5700 at closer
to that $300 price range but we'll talk
more about that towards the end all
right so let's take a look at what we're
working with in terms of specs the 5600
XT actually has the same number of
compute units stream processors and ROPS
as the rx 5700 so we are indeed working
with a cut-down
na
ten GPU that the 50 750 700 XT use
however the boost clock and memory
configuration has been cut down quite a
chunk it's very likely that the 5600 XTS
used reject Navi 10 GPUs which were
otherwise planned for the 50 750 700 XT
but maybe weren't good enough to
maintain some certain clock speeds this
way AMD can improve their yield rate by
salvaging them for other cards now
usually overclocking is a pretty boring
topic for mainstream GPUs but if you're
planning on grabbing the 5,600 X T
there's a couple of things that you
should definitely know firstly out of
the box the 5600 XT will sit at around
1600 megahertz the aftermarket card that
I had on hand did at least and AMD have
imposed some limits here to prevent the
5600 XT from being overclocked
too far for my card and the driver
version that I had on hand I could push
the GPU core to a target of 1820
megahertz in the memory to a target of
1860 megahertz the power limit can be
raised to plus 20% and the V Corps has a
hard cap of 1050 millivolts however I
will note that I only needed around 950
more volts to stabilize our overclock
now the card that I've got you for
testing is the thick 2 pro from XFX
that's thick with 2 C's thankfully just
a 2 slot card though not too thick and
the length for this one comes in at 280
millimeters power connector here is a
recessed 8 pin connector but I can go
design overall with a nice metal
backplate definitely a decent looking
card we will take a look at the thermal
performance towards the end as well so
let's finally take a look at gaming
performance now and the 5,600 XT clearly
is a strong competitor against the 1660
Ti in far cry 5 we see a decent
performance margin on average and a huge
gain in 1% lows Red Dead Redemption to
running the Vulkan API shows fairly
level performance although I do believe
there is some room for driver
optimization here seeing as this is one
of the bigger margins in favor of the
1660 ti apex legends played a bit better
than the 5600 XT around 5% faster on
average here but nothing super
overwhelming or groundbreaking if you
were expecting a 1660 TI Akua
technically yes it's the better
performance in most titles and on
average but it's nothing mind
and there are many titles which will
play perceivably the same on both cards
in doom running on Vulcan the 5,600 XT
was a solid 5% faster than the 1660 TI
but keep an eye on the 1660 super that's
trailing close behind it's 9% slower
here for 18% less cash so again the
5,600 XT is a decent card from AMD not
insanely good value like the rx 50 750
700 XT were but a sensible choice over
the 1660 ti especially in titles that
are optimized for the hardware the 5600
XT can really pack a punch in World War
Z for example we see a nice lead over
the 1660 ti by around 16% on average AMD
definitely nerfed the Navi 10 GPU quite
a bit here though performance isn't
going to be creeping too close to the rx
5,700 especially in games that utilize
higher resolution textures the extra
memory bandwidth on the 50 750 700 XT
will give them a considerable gain
shadow of the Tomb Raider underlines
this very scenario where the 1660 super
does lead the standard 1660 by a decent
margin for those who don't know the 1660
super has GD dr6 memory a bit faster
than the gddr5 on the 1660 so that extra
memory bandwidth is very understated in
my opinion project cars - played
exceptionally well on the new AMD card
around a 10% gain on both average FPS
and 1% lowers over the gtx 660ti and an
acceptable gain in overwatch around 3%
on average and 5% for the 1% lows I did
also get some brief testing done in the
new Star Wars Jedi fallen order before
her gen decided to lock me out for
switching Hardware too many times and
there does seem to be a bit of a driver
issue just for this title
hopefully the public release driver that
goes out today will iron this out but
it's still worth mentioning but the most
important graph of the video is this one
right here this illustrates the overall
value for each GPU tested where the
higher ranked cards offer better value
compared to those are stacked below it
generally the higher performance the GPU
offers they're naturally going to end up
towards the bottom of the stack here and
that's where we see the 5600 XT and the
1660 ti
so on average the 5600 XT does offer
slightly
value than the 1660 TI in the games
tested I found it to be about 4% faster
on average at the same price of course
this chart will heavily depend on the
games that are tested I try and stick to
more popular titles that are out there
at the moment I will highlight the 1660
super here again though I found it to be
just 9% slower on average compared to
the 5,600 XT but for an 18% lower price
if you are on a tiler budget and that
$50.00 allows you to upgrade your CPU or
memory then that's definitely a fair
choice to go with power consumption is
not bad at all about what you'd expect
for a seven nanometer Navi GPU very
similar to the GTX 1660 ti now to
revisit overclocking there's definitely
some games to be had here but nothing
out of the ordinary I did for a second
think that we would see some unreal OC
potential here seeing as the Navi 10 GPU
is clocked fairly low out of the box but
again AMD's hard limits here prevent the
5600 XT from being anything crazy
regarding thermals you really should
have no issues with 5600 XT the TDP here
isn't going to require massive three
slot coolers but it will at least
require an adequate fan speed in the
case of our XFX thick 2 card it just
runs too quiet for its own good
fan speed barely peaked above 1000 rpm
most of the time around 750 but at the
same time memory Junction temps were
consistently 90 degrees C or above keep
in mind this was on an open test bench
with a room ambient of just 22 degrees C
a custom fan curve would be highly
recommended here if you are going with
this card something else I'll mention is
that some rx 5700 models are priced at
as low as 319 to 329 dollars at the
moment so that's a card it definitely
worth considering as well if you are
100% certain on a $279 GPU though the
5600 XT does offer the best value here
however if you are leaning towards the
cheaper end of the 279 dollar price
target I would strongly encourage you to
consider the GTX 1660 super it's not too
much slower for a good chunk less cache
on the other end of the scale though the
5700 is a really solid choice to really
those are my two
of primary recommendations in this kind
of price category the GTX 1660 Supra at
229 dollars and the rx 5700 around 329
339 if you can get it on a good deal the
5600 XT although the best card at 279
dollars doesn't offer you know as
overwhelmingly good value as either of
those cards otherwise guys let me know
your thoughts and comments down below
and whether you are planning on picking
up at the 5600 XT I will have all of
these GPUs that linked down below for
those interested as always guys a huge
thanks for watching and I will see you
all in the next one